هذا موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم قال مسؤول ملف
الاستيطان في شمال الضفه الغربيه غسان
دغلس ان عشرات المستوطنين هاجموا منازل
الاهالي في قريه بورينا واعتدوا عليهم
بالحجاره كما اطلقوا الرصاص الحي في
الهواء ماده الى الحاق اضرار بعدد من
المنازل
يتواصل حصار قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
لقريه حواره جنوبيه نابلس وقد دان وفد
للاتحاد الاوروبي ودبلوماسيين خلال جوله
ميدانيه قام بها في قريه زعتره وبلده
حواره الاعتداءات التي ارتكبها المستوطنون
ودعا الى محاسبه مرتكبها
في مقابله مع الجزيره قال الامين العام
للامم المتحده انطونيو غوتيرفش انه يتعين
على المجتمع الدولي التحرك بقوه لضمان
حمايه القانون في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
واشار الى ان الفلسطينيين يعانون جحيم
من جهته قال المفوض السامي لحقوق الانسان
ان قوات الامن الاسرائيليه استخدمت القوه
المميته ضد الفلسطينيين وبشكل متكرر
نقلت مجله فرن بوليسيه الامريكيه عن مسؤول
امريكي قوله ان السعي ايران للحصول على
منظومه الدفاع الجوي اس 300 او اس 400
الروسيه الصنع سيساعد في حمايه بنيتها
التحتيه النوويه من ضربات اسرائيليه
محتمله
في غضون ذلك قال الجيش الاسرائيلي انه
انهى مناورات بريه مشتركه مع قوات من
المارينز الامريكيه شملت لاول مره محاكاه
تنسيق ضربه جويه محتمله لمنشات نوويه
ايرانيه
من جهه اخرى قال البانتاجون ان رئيس هيئه
الاركان المشتركه مارك ميلي بحث امس في تل
ابيب مع المسؤولين الاسرائيليين التنسيق
المشتركه للتصدي للتهديدات التي تشكلها
طهران
قال الرئيس مجموعه فاغنر الروسيه
بشكل شبه كامل وان هناك طريقا واحدا فقط
لخروج القوات الاوكرانيه من المدينه
قال فرحان حقنائب المتحدث باسم الامين
العام للامم المتحده ان الاف السكان
محاصرون في باخمت واضاف ان من بقي من
شركاء الامم المتحده في المدينه يعملون
على اجلاء المحتاجين من السكان
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه انها ستزود
اوكرانيا بمعدات عسكريه بقيمه 400 مليون
دولار واوضح ان المساعدات تتضمن لاول مره
جسورا تكتيكيه مدرعه تساعد الدبابات
والعربات المدرعه في عبور الانهار
والخنادق
تمسكت جبهه الخلاص المعارضه بتنظيم
احتجاجات يوم غد الاحد رغم رفض السلطات
التونسيه ذلك ومن جهته على الاتحاد
التونسي للشغل الى مظاهرات احتجاجيه اليوم
وقال ان الحكومه اغلقت ابواب المفاوضات
والحوار
من جانب قال الرئيس قيس سعيد ان اتحاد
الشغل حر في تنظيم لكنه ليس حرا في دعوه
الاجانب للمشاركه
وقال الامين العام للامم المتحده في
مقابله مع الجزيره انه لا بد من العمل من
اجل الحفاظ على الديمقراطيه في تونس واضاف
انه لا ينبغي ان يعتقل او يعتقل اي شخص
على خلفيه رايه السياسي
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]